we're all about a amazing service a
perfect service every day for each older
adult because there's no do-overs when
you're a human Carrington other human hi
my name is Josh Bruno I'm the co-founder
and CEO of home team I'm 28 years old I
was working as an investor previously
and for five years I watched my family
really struggled to care for my
grandfather he lived to be 98 but in age
of 93 to 98 he needed extra help in the
home and we couldn't provide that for
him
and so I was frustrated with all the
solutions out there and really wanted to
find a better way to care for older
adults in the home
yeah the technology comes in in two ways
one you want to match caregivers with an
older adult based on their skills but
also their interests and their passion
for helping each other
so that means that somebody with
experience in Parkinson's is caring for
someone with Parkinson's and we do these
things with software also in the home to
understand what's happening just
day-to-day we use technology in that
home give you a summary of what's
happening and pictures and videos from
each day that your parents are being
taken care of this is a human business
and it involves humans interacting with
others and that this work can never be
completely replaced by technology and so
after we'd raised our first couple
rounds of funding we went out for a
third round of funding and because we
had that human element we were turned
down by almost everyone that was a
difficult moment you know we had to stay
true to our model though understand that
this is still going to be immune to
human business and continue to grow and
I'm happy to say that that since then
we've brought on more incredible
partners and have continued to fund the
business